[Music]
you've explained beautifully what
laughter is and how it happens but why
do we do it yeah why would such a thing
evolve yeah yeah it is hard
there's partly there's that there's a
fedora wind there's a rather sin that
speaking of evolution there's a rather
thin line between laughing and being
afraid you know it's not obvious when
some animals as it were smiling or when
they're baring their teeth in aggression
or fear so I'm not quite sure about its
evolutionary function but it's um I
think the thing is the thing about it is
that it's a kind of dysfunctionality if
you like us the way I presented it it's
when things moments really break down or
crash but it's not really it's not
really a useful dysfunctionality any
more than ours is yeah I mean in a sense
there's no point to a joke there can be
a point to a joke of course joke can be
used aggressively or indeed used simply
to communicate but Freud makes a
distinction between what he calls jokes
and jests and Jess are really for him
just bits of wordplay which have no
point beyond themselves there's
something what Seamus Heaney once talked
about poetry as Mouse music yes poetry
with the poets of people who are so
infantile that they can't invest in the
external world but they invest you know
in the very organs of speech themselves
yes and that becomes an end in itself as
it were and there's a kind of jesting or
jerking which I think is that sort of
thing but otherwise it serves a whole
lot of social function doesn't it from I
they say for aggression wounding satire
is very important you know
sarcasm which literally means tearing
the flesh to to establishing community
but often for its own sake yeah I have
again in the book I talk about the
history of humor and the politics of
humor and how humor can be instrumental
to a kind of enlightenment but it can
also be as it were done just for the
hell of it like most like most valuable
things it's done just for the hell of it
yeah he doesn't really have a point
beyond itself hi and I was interested in
what he said about the historically
having been kind of mass breakout serve
of laughter that people have died in are
those apocryphal stories or are they I
don't think so I mean fumblin might be
but but I think it is true that people
have died laughing and of course what's
interesting about that is the
contagiousness of laughter isn't it one
of the ways in which laughter spreads
but not always very positively is by a
kind of contagiousness like a disease
yeah you're like yeah like some disease
you don't know where you've gotten up
from don't know how you came to you and
I is true yes so that that's what one
sense in which laughter is I mean we
speak of hysterical laughter where
laughter is very close to being
extremely alarming and where again the
line between fear or aggression and
enjoyment is blood could you say
something about the tradition of jokes
bees are only very very slightly funny
well my jokes are so hilarious that I
really do anything about that I do
believe there are more jokes please
well I don't know I mean I suppose there
must be something here somewhere
well I mean there are degrees of success
in humor as there are in art or any form
of communication no humor is not is not
guaranteed and is notoriously culturally
relative yes for example on one of my
first visit to China I was told that um
to be on my guard when people started
smiling because it meant embarrassment
and they were embarrassed and indeed
there was a famous occasion when I
managed to embarrass them very much so
what counts as funny there is both from
a culture to one culture to another
and of course historically as well yes I
mean a lot of a lot of jokes from the
past now to our seem gloriously unfunny
there is a history of laughter which
again I talked about in the book which I
think in literature starts with the
Iliad somebody laughs in the Iliad and
there's also of course a biblical
history of laughter for example God
laughing sadistically people in hell is
one of the you know less Christian
example so that tradition of snarling or
sardonic laughter is not simply confined
to the to the Devils to the demons yes
it it has a there's a kind of sacred
history there as well there's a lady
here yeah yeah I was wondering if you
could say something about laughter as a
form of triumph as in when the evil
villain is about to dispatch the hero
yeah and gives them
sinister laugh yeah and also would your
book help my partner stand up cooler
he'll help you apart standard courier oh
absolutely I would be the making of it
but
but since since I intend to have one
myself
I already yes triumphant laughter well
there are different forms of triumphant
laughter around there triumphant
laughter is one of the many forms of
laughter which you're not particularly
something funny
you don't always laugh at something
funny yes and one of the puzzles also is
that not all incongruities are funny one
of the defects of the incongruity theory
of laughter which covers more apparently
than most series is that there are
incongruity which are really not
particularly funny at all either neutral
or positively unpleasant yeah so try and
try and felicitate laughter yes laughter
either laughter as exuberance because
you conquered all you've succeeded or of
course the great German shot and Freud
er yes laughing of somebody else's
disability or somebody else's pain which
is a classic example of the superiority
theory of laughter which is I mean there
may be an element of sadism in a lot of
laughter even apparently innocent
laughter or even masochism but try
triumph can take various forms it can
take for example the form of stage
comedy we laugh at stage comedy even at
you know upsets and pratfalls and
dislocations and potentially potentially
lethal events because we know that
everything will be restored in the end
it's a very comforting form of fantasy
you know in the end there will be what
some what's the basic rhythm of an era T
if you start with a kind of situation it
becomes disintegrated something happens
somebody goes on the road or somebody
comes along and then you have a process
of disintegration and then you have a
triumphant restoration the end although
in Shakespeare notably you very often
have a character who stands aside from
Malvolio say at the end of Twelfth Night
you know I'll be revenged on the package
who stands aside from the final
synthesis in order to gesture to its
unreality yeah
or when Prospero says yeah please
release me from my bands with the help
of your good hands he say he means
applaud applaud white because then you
will recognize that this is a fiction
yes and then the spell of fantasy will
be broken and you'll be able to leave
the theatre and take with you whatever
you've learned from the play so one of
the alarming points however about comedy
you know is that um you may you may
conclude that poetic justice is now only
possible in fiction you know I mean if
you look at somebody like say Tom Jones
and the 80th century or any of those
comic heroes or heroines it's pretty
lightly they were in reality being
hanged you know in prison what does it
say about a certain kind of society if
the only form of justice you can
dispense even-handedly now requires the
artifice of fiction yeah so that fiction
the artifice of fiction no longer
reflects the actual world as it does
when comedy when the comic is related to
the cosmic yes I mean the Dante's Divine
Comedy is called the comedy because as
you will know they're not very many
evils in it but of course it's comedy in
that different sense that the world
itself is a carrying of our artifact and
that and that despite all appearances
this is the perhaps the most the deepest
sense of comedy despite all occurrences
all is well may not look like that but
it is you know that's also of course
tightly a Christian message despite
despite crucifixion it's not quite the
last words not quite the last word but
unless you face that unless you confront
the very worst you can't transcend it
you can transcend it and tragedy just to
switch to that mode is I suppose them
in which we have to open ourselves to
the real to what is unspeakable and
intolerable in order to try and get
beyond it as somebody Edgar says in Lea
the worst is not so long as we can say
this is the worst so long as we can
still articulate it
it's not the end yeah I won't if you say
something about political satire why
doesn't it seem to work we seem to have
particularly in our culture a strong
belief in its efficacy but it seems to
produce the opposite if you look at boys
Johnson who's been sort of mercilessly
mocked it's been on have I got news for
you and yet his popularity seems to
increase and think of Peter Cook and his
comment about all that Vimal satire
didn't seem to do much good just wonder
if you have any thoughts on that yes
well I mean people quite like buffoons
Boris Johnson as people have always
liked clowns partly because they can
feel superior to them but also because
the town is all licensed the clown can
transgress Olivia in Twelfth Night says
there's no harm in a licensed fool no I
mean as long as that's your job you know
a fool with a capital F certainly Boris
Johnson is then then you're okay because
then people come as it will harmlessly
indulge their own little fears or
pleasures knowing that it's not really
going to going to make any difference
that's the sort of the point really you
say why doesn't it make a difference
well that's one reason he's not meant to
make that kind of difference I don't
know
you know satire gives itself very high
pretensions to correct vice to purge
purge evil to reform society think of
Alexander Pope and so on but has it ever
really done that I don't know certainly
not by itself I think but there is some
I've got here in the book there's a
there's a chapter that
to the play by an old friend of mine
chef Griffis to play comedians and in
comedians I mean it is very much it is
the play par excellence about the
politics of humor of how humor can
degrade and humiliate and how it can be
a man Centauri yeah but the line is
often pretty brief in give-up sounds
very erudite but likes a lot of analysis
of humor it seems to be fixated in the
past a little you quote Griffis you
quote wild but monkeys but it seems to
me certainly stand-up is moved on
tremendously its long form it's about
attitude it's about a comic persona and
people aren't laughing it's sudden
reversals whether it be reverses or
fortunes or expectations that laughing
is something else yes well as I say if
somebody somebody's born in the early
years of the Industrial Revolution
that's not the path to me meanwhile drew
yes of course humor changes and you and
you're right the theory of sudden
reversals on is not exhaustive by any
means you're quite correct one one
interesting aspect of stand-up among
many and you know the revival of that
comic popular art form is tremendously
important I think is that you can do a
kind of meta meta humor I'm supposed to
be doing the gig with Stuart Lee in
London did that yes that double or
treble take which has always been in a
sense there in the shoe in the comic
tradition that has become a lot more
important partly because we've become
much more knowing yes we were you know
certain kinds of humor presuppose a
certain kind of naive T which is in a
streetwise postmodern society what work
for more debates tops and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you